[Music]
whether it's a self-driving car or a
machine that will deliver you anything
you want at the top of the button the
world's innovators have come a long way
but what are some products you can buy
now that will totally change the way you
live if you are a first-time viewer
click the red subscribe button because
today we are discussing ten seriously
brilliant inventions that will change
your life mind flicks spending the day
in bed watching Netflix is what many
people will consider a day well spent
the Netflix engineers want to make the
experience even easier for their users
by introducing mind flicks my Netflix is
a band you wear around your head
that tracks brainwaves which help you
navigate Netflix this means you can
control Netflix with your mind not only
would you not have to put on you don't
even have to get out from under the
covers because mind flicks will do all
the work wine wipes having a glass of
wine after a long day of work is the
norm for many people but sometimes the
wine stains on your teeth and lips
Stamper the experience that is where
wine wipes come in the wine wives help
remove stains from your teeth and lips
and the best part is they don't have a
taste this means they don't affect the
taste of your wine now you can enjoy all
the wine you want without the
embarrassment of a purple wine mouth
disposable phone charger how many times
have you been out around town and your
phone starts to die probably more times
than you would like the problem is
regular portable chargers are pretty
clunky
and you have to remember the charging
cable you might want to consider
disposable chargers instead the little
cardboard chargers are like a boost for
your dying phone they come with charges
good for two to six hours of phone time
and they are even biodegradable piece of
scissors there is an issue with making
pizza at home trying to figure out the
right time to cut it without ripping off
all the toppings if you ever have to
deal with this issue then it is time to
invest in pizza scissors the pizza
scissors make cutting your favorite
pizza I breeze and the best part is you
don't have to worry about measuring the
perfect slice because it has a slice
measurer bills right in cuddle mattress
if you have a significant other
the
you probably know that getting a good
cuddle is amazing but sometimes you
might be left with an uncomfortable dead
arm this is where the ingenious cuddle
mattress comes in the cuddle mattress
features three inch wide slats that
easily part allowing you to slide your
arm inside and under your significant
other now you can get close to your
partner without cutting off the
circulation in your arm chi patch living
in a warm climate may mean having
year-round sunshine but you may have to
deal with pesky mosquitoes there haven't
been many options to get rid of
mosquitoes outside of smelly sprays and
Dinky candles but now you can prevent
mosquito bites and the potentially
deadly diseases they carry by wearing a
kite patch the easy to wear patch helps
to disrupt the carbon monoxide neurons
of mosquitoes which makes you and your
blood harder for mosquitoes to find
smart frying-pan you may be someone who
would love to be able to cook yourself a
homemade meal but sadly you have no idea
what you are doing in the kitchen
thankfully there is a solution for your
problem the smart frying pan the smart
frying pan connects through an app on
your phone the app tells you temperature
settings window flip your food and win
to add ingredients it even has an
autopilot feature that controls the
temperature itself all you need to do is
work the spatula self-cleaning hair
brush if you are someone with long hair
then you know the struggle with cleaning
your brush even if you do get it clean
chances are there are a few strands left
behind the good news is there is a new
brush that will blow all your old hair
brushes away the self-cleaning hair
brush has a pad at the base of the
bristles so when it's time to clean it
you just lift the pad and gather all the
hair and throw it away
cleaning slime have you ever been typing
on your computer's keyboard and notice
that is actually pretty disgusting drops
of food dust you name it keyboards can
get messy but how are you supposed to
clean this mess without affecting your
computer's hardware look no further than
cleaning slime the sticky slime is
perfect for hard-to-reach places and
safe for your electronics you can even
find easy DUI cleanin slime rest
he's on line to make your own smart
contacts it may sound like something out
of a sci-fi novel but smart contacts are
becoming a real thing they will be able
to hold tiny cameras monitor your health
and even give you supervision
the idea behind smart contacts is to be
able to see an augmented and mixed
reality with the ability to take photos
and recordings this technology won't
only change your life but possibly the
world
how many of these brilliant inventions
do you want react in the comments
section below and don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things
[Music]